[Applause]
[Music]
music canada
has just confirmed gold certification on
your first
radio single outlaws and outsiders
featuring
tripp ivan moody and mick mars man
congratulations
ah thank you so much oh there it is we
got something special for you right
there look at that oh
man that's amazing
et canada thank you so much this is
amazing
what people like about this song one of
the things anyways it's this mashup
of genres that just makes sense
the most important part for me is not
only that i want to make sure it was
you know country but i came from a rock
background too you know i really wanted
to
mix that up and and really give country
music a different sound a different lane
to go down
and uh i'm really uh really proud and
proud about that and glad
this is a worldwide hit so what was it
like going to single together
uh well you know it all started being
across canada on a cross-country tour
with
my good friend aaron purchette on the
outlaws and outsiders tour
and i just thought man uh the way things
were going at canadian country radio
with me that's really how i felt
an outlaw on an outsider and i thought
that'd be a great title or great hook
for a song
we ended up writing this song and ended
up being you know a huge smash for me
globally which uh
again i'm really thankful for it
[Music]
it takes too much time
[Music]
we wanted uh you know a real outlaw a
real country outlaw and
uh you know i mean it doesn't get much
better than that he was best friends
with waylon jennings and so
uh to be able to have travis trippy part
of this this song
a huge part of the song was a true honor
for me and again very thankful
that he's part of this so has this has
always been the dream then for you
hasn't it
you know what uh it's it's a funny story
i i never really dreamt of being a
singer i actually always wanted to be uh
a drummer so i i've been drawing since
the age of 10 and singing didn't come
till i was about 20 or 21 so
later in my you know high school college
days is when it all kind of started for
me
how would you describe to anyone who
hasn't heard it yet how would you
describe who i am
who i am uh well it's the story of my
life in that time it's got the good bad
and the ugly and if i could
kind of crunch it all together it's a
little bit merle haggard
it's a little bit eric church and it's a
little bit ozzy osbourne now let's talk
about
blame it on the double
yeah so blame it on a double is
obviously a party party anthem
your uh your typical saturday night with
a group of friends
uh going out getting in a little bit of
trouble but having fun doing it
everybody's got that drink that when
when their friend
offers it to them they're like no i
can't because
it's gonna make me turn up too much and
then you end up doing it anyways what's
that one for you what's that drink for
you
well it depends how many drinks i had
before that drink but
uh it doesn't really matter
i'll try anything once